I have for you today an absolute
supernova leaked recording okay in 2016
a full month before Donald Trump became
the Republican nominee there were
already some people suspecting that
Donald Trump was connected to Vladimir
Putin that is not a surprise what we
have now learned and I'm going to play
some Washington Post video for you here
is that one of the people who in the
summer of 2016
thought that Paul Ryan I'm sorry that
Donald Trump was connected to Vladimir
Putin was Republican congressman Kevin
McCarthy and Paul Ryan immediately tried
to shut down those concerns saying don't
talk about that the bombshell nature is
stunning Republican House Majority
Leader Kevin McCarthy on June 15th in a
recorded meeting said to other
Republicans that he believes Trump as
well as Republican congressman Dana
Rohrabacher might be on the payroll of
Vladimir Putin again a Republican said
this a full month before Trump became
the Republican nominee House Speaker
Paul Ryan immediately interjected
shutting down the entire conversation
let's listen to this video from the
Washington Post put the seat belts on
get the kids out of the room here is the
first part of this the day before this
meeting with the Ukrainian Prime
Minister the news breaks the Washington
Post's breaks it that the DNC has been
hacked by the Russians so McCarthy
basically takes the conversation and
turns it to what is happening in the
United States he begins by saying I'll
guarantee you that's what it is
the Russians hacked the DNC and got the
OP research that they had on Trump and
then McCarthy laughs McCarthy then adds
there's two people I think Putin pays
Rohrbacher and Trump there's then
laughter by some of the lawmakers in the
room and then McCarthy adds swear to God
Ryan then interjects and says quote this
isn't off the record no leaks all right
Ryan then adds this is how we know we're
a real family he
Wow Wow The Washington Post also went to
Paul Ryan's office to try to get a
comment and here is again a demand to
stream the Washington Post who is
narrating this he explains what happened
when they tried to get a comment from
Paul Ryan we first approached Ryan in
McCarthy's offices to tell them we were
publishing this and we told them what we
were gonna have Ryan in McCarthy saying
and their response was to say it never
happened that there was no conversation
like this they said that it was untrue
they called it fiction later we told
them that we had a transcript of the
conversation and then they suggested
that the transcript was false that it
was maybe even made-up certainly
inaccurate they said when we told them
finally that we had listened to an audio
recording of this conversation they
adjusted their statement and what Ryan's
office told us was that that McCarthy
had delivered in effect an inappropriate
joke and that he was not intending to be
serious so the conversation never
happened
okay the conversation did happen but the
transcript you have is not an accurate
transcript oh the transcript you have is
exactly the same as the tape that you
obtained well the entire thing happened
but it was all a joke
and if McCarthy was the one joking why
did Paul Ryan react the way that he
reacted the obvious takeaway is that
Republicans knew or at least suspected a
long time ago almost a year ago exactly
what Trump was all along a joke and once
they can no longer deny it it's a joke I
don't think you're gonna be too
surprised by this but I really don't buy
the third excuse of it because if
McCarthy said swear to God that implies
that it's not a joke right and if the
whole crowd erupts and laughter then
it's not a bad attempt at a joke it's a
joke that hit yeah it's it's very it's a
very strange argument to make I say
subpoena everyone Robert Moeller get
them all in and let's figure out what's
going on and of course there's people
saying David you haven't heard the tape
so it's obviously untrue would the Paul
Ryan would Paul Ryan's office now say it
happened but it was a joke
if the tape didn't exist I mean come on
this is like when people were saying the
Trump Russia leak thing isn't true
Trump went on Twitter and defended doing
it how can you still say that it's not
true I just don't get how people can
argue that nothing nothing happened Paul
Ryan's office has commented on it
assuming that it happened I mean it's
possible maybe that the Washington Post
has a transcript but they were bluffing
on the idea of a tape to get them to
respond in a different fashion but you
could tell just by Ryan's response that
there's a clear separation between the
Washington elite and the rest of the
American public yes and he's clearly
putting party ahead of country here I
will say I will say today's program made
possible in part by movement watches I'm
wearing my movement watch today people
love it people see it they ask me about
it I tell them hey it's movement watch's
movement watches was started by two
broke college guys in a dorm room they
wanted a cool watch they would go to a
department store the watches they liked
were five hundred dollars so by selling
directly online by using crowdfunding to
launch their company just as the david
pakman show used crowdfunding to launch
and grow our program they sell directly
to the customer watches start at ninety
five bucks
they are very stylish they look like
watches that would cost way more but
they only cost a fraction of what you
would pay in a department store my
viewers and listeners can save 15% as
well as free shipping and free returns
by going to M V M T watches dot-com
slash Pakman step-up your watch game MVM
t watches comm /p a que ma n